an overdue honor for an often overlooked
American president and military
commander on Friday President Biden
signed a measure authorizing a record
858 billion dollars for the Pentagon the
National Defense authorization act
includes pay raises for service members
funding for ships tanks and aircraft and
Military Support for Taiwan and Ukraine
but buried within the legislation is a
provision giving Ulysses S Grant a
promotion to the military's highest rank
David Martin explains why it's coming
157 years after the Civil War ended
General Ulysses S Grant had been
consigned to history as the stalard and
plotting Union general who defeated the
daring and dashing Confederate General
Robert E Lee no longer if there's an
historic wrong let's make it right
Senator Sherrod Brown sponsored a
provision in the massive defense
spending bill that promotes Grant to
General of the armies a rank held by
only two other Americans
George Washington commander of the
Revolutionary Army and blackjack
Pershing commander of American forces in
World War one I think it's always good
to revisit history and to shine a bright
light on those who have done well Brown
could be accused of bias and sees the
senator from Ohio which was Grant's home
state but ask retired General David
Petraeus Grant truly was the man who
saved the union his actions more than
any other individual in uniform that
ultimately ensured that the north won
that war and that the union was
preserved as America's deadliest war
ground on with no end in sight President
Lincoln turned in desperation to Grant
who took command and chased Lee all the
way to the courthouse at Appomattox and
accepted his surrender he is arguably
the greatest Battlefield General in
American military history no other U.S
army General did what he did did which
was to demonstrate true Brilliance on
the battlefield
every level of warfare a portrait quite
at odds with many of the historical
depictions of Grant he was dismissed as
incompetent or corrupt or an alcoholic
That Couldn't manage his demons and his
alcohol Lincoln when told that Grant
drank famously responded to find out
what he drinks it would give it to the
other generals at least he fights the
wheel of History has turned and Grant
now stands on a pedestal with only two
other Americans while statues of Robert
E Lee are coming down
for CBS Saturday morning this is David
Martin at the Pentagon
interesting ways peace started if
there's a historic run let's make it
right something to remember